should be going live and I will of
course tweet about it do you think Lisa
other planets have Twitter
they have Twitter or I have the next
thing coming what are we gonna do
whatever that's how they they decided
not to come here you know because they
saw and they saw us on Twitter and uh I
think there's a lot of things going for
that you know when you were saying about
this you know why we haven't been
visited you know I think I have a couple
of good ideas off that might have
nothing to do with an eerie silence
oh that's wonderful and I can't wait to
get into it and really nerd out with one
of my favorite finds from around the
universe that's Dr Lisa carltoneger of
Cornell University she is the Carl Sagan
Center founding director where she's
been uh that in that role since at least
2015 and I brought along one my only
prop today I have two props I've got
some samples of a Proto planet that
never formed AKA a meteorite and then I
have this guy here you recognize this
guy of course Carl Sagan we're talking
about Cornell University and the call
second Institute so there was a reason
why we actually came here and why the
inspiration for searching for life in
the universe is just so deeply rooted at
Cornell yeah and I had my roots there
almost I was almost born like Cornell my
father was a professor there and he left
just a couple of years before I was born
to go down to Stony Brook down we'll
take it we'll take it you were cornelian
right now you know it's just one of
these things well Lisa I'm glad that you
say that because the admissions officers
did never say that not for undergrad and
not for graduate school we're not I'm
not bitter Lisa I'm not bitter but I
have had the honor of how you're not the
first cornelian not to be honor the
first uh ethicalian or whatever ithacan
uh because I've had on um both andrurian
Carl Sagan's uh lovely lovely writing
partner spouse Muse and uh and also his
daughter Sasha Sagan they've both been
guests on the podcast that's amazing
yeah my first ever mother-daughter you
know kind of team up and that was just
delightful so Carl Loom's large over
almost everything uh you know that we
think about in in the search for other
worlds but even in things ranging from
the search for uh the search for our own
humanity and I wonder we'll get into a
discussion of of whether or not Carl's
dream of you know detecting the Earth
from a distance uh could be made more
visualized by the work that you're doing
now you're a theorist but you work very
closely with observations with
forecasting
um I was telling you before we started
uh broadcasting that uh I had always
known of your work and actually we had
been scheduled I've been scheduled to
give a colloquium there I think it's
still waiting for you march 2020. I I
don't remember what happened back then
it's all a blur uh but I will come back
but uh but I was of course aware of you
for so long
um your your reputation is is so well
deserved and and you do so much not only
in the public Sphere for for you know
popularizing the work that we do and I
think that's a moral obligation that
scientists have to give back to the
public because they pay our salaries at
some level or they funded our education
but more than that uh you do a great
service to the scientists in your field
by providing a benchmark of what a good
scientist uh looks like and what they
should how they should approach a field
both interacting with experimentalists
like me observers uh like uh pass guests
on the show and of course with theorists
and today we're going to be talking
about your work uh inspired by this
Quantum magazine article uh most
recently that is rumored to be one of
the most popular I don't want to make
any of my friends jealous or betray any
secrets I did talk to the editor Thomas
there not too long ago and he said it
was one of their most popular ever and
it's well deserved So Lisa we're going
to talk about your work but first I do
want to start with your quick origin
story how did the origin of life the
life of Lisa get started please give us
a a brief intro into what brought you to
being the founding director of the Sega
Institute well I am actually from a tiny
tiny town in Austria so there are about
a thousand people in the town and
whenever I come back they still wave out
of the car at me and I was like oh
you're back you know that kind of town
and from that it was actually never
really in the cards I thought to become
a university Professor you know small
country not really a space agency but in
Austria we can choose what we pick to
study and so I was curious about
everything around me and you'll see that
probably it's one of those things in my
work I think an exoplanet is so
fascinating to me especially and it was
like one because there's so many puzzle
pieces that you need to put together to
understand what you're seeing or to
figure out what you need to now observe
with this big telescopes and by the way
I'm gonna I'm on theorist right now
because we didn't have telescopes that
could do it so I'm starting to get
closer and closer to an observer aspect
and I'll tell you about all the stuff I
grow in the labs I'm actually starting
to become an experimentalist too because
it's a lot of fun to put these pieces
together but yes theory is definitely
the core of what I do
and so
in 1995 when I started to study
they found the first planet to run
another star and the people who found
them are just incredibly nice people I
met them at a conference like Michelle
mayora and Didier Killers they're just
great and the interesting things they're
both Swiss right and they found them in
Switzerland so Switzerland has a lot of
mountains Austria has a lot of mountains
Switzerland is pretty small Austria is
pretty small right and I was like hey if
they can do this then maybe just very
very maybe you know I can do this too
but of course I saw nobody who looked
like me anywhere so then I went to my
first meeting in car chase like in in
Corsica it was like a tiny meeting and
it was in 98 so three years after and
they were I think we were about 50
people so I shared a room with Sarah
Sega because you know we were just four
girls and the whole fast guest on the
podcast three-time guest on the podcast
perfect and so basically that's where I
got to to me a lot of super interesting
people in
I saw that this hierarchy can break down
so there was like this Steve Professor
asking my opinion about things that I
didn't know much about because on an
undergrad at that time and then they
were saying well we're looking we're
trying to figure out how we could find
life in the in these planets and I'm
like oh my God is there really an option
that I could help trying to figure out
if we're alone in the universe and I
think from there it spiraled in so far
that I was like okay maybe it's really
true maybe I can really do something
like that and then I went to the
European Space Agency to do part of my
PhD they were looking for young
engineers and have an engineering degree
and a science degree so that worked out
well and I only applied for one Mission
it was called the Darwin Mission and it
was supposed to search for planets like
ours and figure out if there was life
and from all these applicants they
picked me what was really interesting
because I was like why do you do that
but apparently like having engineering
Optics background and the theory
background and astronomy was not as
usual so then I went to Holland and then
from there it kind of went the way that
we designed a telescope to try to find
life and we'll get to that in and when
we talk a little bit more about work but
the interesting thing was like nobody
could tell me
how the Earth would have looked like
earlier we were looking for carbon copy
of modern Earth in all our design
choices and I was like what but what a
body of the earth is younger right I
can't tell you what's going to happen if
the Earth is older because we don't have
any data yet we just have models and
nobody knew and so then basically I
talked to somebody at Harvard what was
pretty funny right so I'm in this
meeting I'm talking about that we really
need to model uh the evolution of Earth
through time and nobody's taking me up
on it and I learned why because it's so
hard to do you know the naivete about
this is possible it's a lot of energetic
capital in the beginning when you're
trying to do a huge project as you well
now and then uh West trobe at the
Harvard Smithsonian Center for
astrophysics said well if you think it's
you need to do this you know then you'll
just have to do it yourself you know if
you think it's worth doing you have to
do it and so this is how I then went to
Harvard and then from her I went and
built my team at the Max Planck
Institute in Germany when they were
saying oh maybe you want to build our
team here and I was like yeah I can do
that and coming back you know to Europe
was also a great choice
and then uh Cornell caught and they were
saying well you know we would really
like you to come here and so I think
that was the first time I actually knew
where Canal was and I also was the first
time I ever went to Cornell so you know
you have some time still so that phone
call was incredibly Pleasant and then
they were saying well what would
convince you to come and join us and I
was like well I really want to work in
this interdisciplinary uh team that's
basically one of the key things in my
research I think if you understand the
planet you need to understand the
biology you need to understand the
chemistry and the engineering to figure
out how to find it and so on
and I can do quite some of it but not
all of it there's no way we can do this
anymore right to know everything there
is and so I said well I want to work in
this institute and then they turn around
it's like well if you think it's worth
doing and having this institute you'll
have to build one and leave it again I
saw that coming I should have seen that
coming in the best possible way this is
how the Carl Sagan Institute here got
started in my work room I bribed people
from all the different departments with
really good coffee so my startup was
spent very well on coffee machines and
espresso machines and then you know dark
Belgium chocolate and some good cakes so
if you ever come by and want to talk
about research you know we have the best
coffee on campus and so we have an
incredibly striving team because you
know scientists do like coffee and
groceries not a place to talk about yes
that's true
well I am just blown away by kind of the
the essence of what you're doing and I
always feel like it's a question for me
you know how do you um how do you
understand uh a project when there may
not be an answer at the end and you may
not be successful detecting life and
that's that's okay and I might not be
successful detecting you know waves of
gravity from the early universe and
that's okay too but on a daily basis
what keeps you going I mean is it the
knowledge that there are so many planets
I mean as andrurian and as Carl Sagan
right in um in their book contact which
became a famous movie Loosely based on
other cornelian and two-time guests on
the show Jill Tarter
um who's maiden name do you know what
her maiden name was no I don't actually
Cornell
almost positive it's Cornell someone in
the chat room correct me if I'm wrong
but anyway
um and she was at Corona obviously and
and she is still a towering figure and a
mentor to Millions but you know as they
write in that book uh if there isn't
life in the universe it's an awful waste
of space okay and I'd never like that
because I've been to Antarctica twice
which isn't you know quite as uh as
luxurious with uh replete with chocolate
as is Austria or Belgium or now it
sounds like Ithaca absolutely I've been
there twice and you know it's one
seventh of all the continents on earth
and so you might think naively if you're
just a dumb experimentalist like me you
might say Well it must have one seventh
of the life on Earth there and it's like
point one percent of all the life on
Earth you know it's a couple of penguins
which are really cute uh and some some
nasty birds called skus which are like
literal like like seagulls on steroids
that will eat anything uh chocolate or
not they'll eat your luggage
um but that's about it there's some
there's 200 nerds you know on the planet
in the middle of winter down there which
is uh coming up in about six months but
anyway Lisa the the supposition that you
know space is tantamount to probability
has always troubled me about your field
so I'm not I'm not putting you on the
spot I hope too much but what do you
make of this argument that well there's
so many you know planets on on uh in the
universe there has to be the potential
for Life what do you make of those kinds
of arguments let me go one point just
about what you were talking about life
there's actually I have an amazing
postdoc right now she was a PhD student
with me who went to Hudson Bay and
scooped up this lifeless goo and we
found like such a diversity of biota in
there like not Penguins I would have
liked the picture of the bigger luckily
it's also no problem
but there is so much diverse microbial
life in there and then you just kind of
have to imagine that if these were the
the main condition on the planet there
could actually be advances in that kind
of life form too that we just don't see
here because it's just Niche
environments as you were saying and so I
agree but let's come back to your
question absolutely so is it a numbers
game and I like to use like made the
numbers be forever in our favor right
because we know that one out of five
stars from everything we know from the
small region and around our star like
about thousand two thousand light years
around where we are actually look at
plants are under the stars we find that
one out of well one out of two at least
has a planet and one out of five that's
the amazing number has a planet that's
small enough to be a rock and at the
right distance to not be too hot and too
cold so yes but I agree with you now how
do you go from that huge number 200
billion stars in the galaxy so one out
of five roughly gets you to 40 billions
of course you have to be careful because
in the middle that's the black hole much
more Stellar density there might be not
enough Metals in some regions but we're
talking billions and billions you know
basically channeling calls saying it on
this show but with hacking possibilities
right
but now what's really fascinating is
that we can make life in the lab
that was one thing that for example I
didn't know yes I should have known but
I didn't know that we can do that and so
if we can't make life in the lab yet we
do not know if small changes in the
initial conditions could actually leave
upon a baron if you want or if there are
huge changes in condition and still life
will evolve maybe differently right
because on the earth we also think it
got a couple of starts but we don't know
that and so this is why I agree with you
if you have like a couple of billions
multiplied by zero yes you still have
zero and I love if you multiply by one
you have a huge number but I love
Michelle mayor got this question in one
of the talks when I was at Harvard and
they were like so what's the probability
of life and Michelle was so funny he
said 50 and it was like oh my God and he
said plus minus 50. yes and that's
exactly where we are and this is in a
way why this is so fascinating right
because if we knew already it wouldn't
be cutting edge research anymore if if
you knew that the gravitational waves
would come from the beginning of the Big
Bang or just just slightly after you
know what would be the fun and trying to
puzzle out how to potentially do it and
you were asking how I feel about you
know this uh at this stage in our time
uh maybe I'm gonna find life hopefully
maybe not right
and what I love about science is that we
are connected through time we basically
I use things that Kepler found I use
relativity universities that Einstein
you know put together and so to me
the scientific knowledge is in a way
like this huge firmament so there's this
other kind of sky where we all are like
tiny points that add something to it and
with that we created the knowledge that
puts Humanity forward and yes of course
I want to find life in the universe not
even a question but maybe if I can't
my contribution will allow the next
person to step off there and find it and
when I talk to my students I think about
it this way if in the Far Far Future and
I hope we're going to get a Star Trek
kind of spaceship right somebody sets
out to another planet they might have
this tiny antique map you know from the
first time when scientists got around to
say oh this might be an interesting
planet and they might just look at it
and they might be smiling and laughing a
little bit like when we look at the
antique Loops but maybe I was a person
who put those planets on the map and so
even if I'm not there in person but I
did well then travel through the Stars
uh that's delightful and true and I want
to uh first I want to make an offer even
though I wasn't accepted at Cornell two
times I'm not gonna dwell on this their
fault I'm not bitter I'm not bitter at
all it doesn't sound like I'll come out
for that chocolate uh I wanna I wanna
turn very briefly to uh your thoughts as
a theorist as an as an astrophysicist on
the what we can say statistically about
objects like this I told you I've got
two prop Ops one is Carl Sagan this is a
meteorite which was discovered in
Argentina at the so-called Campo de
Cielo in uh about three or four hundred
years ago
and I bring this up because of two
things one I'm going to give them away
to your students anyone with a edu email
list automatically wins one of these and
the rest of you non-educated uh Cornell
or Not by the way it could be anywhere
that with a edu address so if you join
my mailing list which is that linked
right over there you will get your own
sample I'm going to bring you a much
bigger sample when I come visit you Lisa
but what can we say about the fact that
there's material exchanged all around
the solar system for millions of years
including from I have a tiny tiny
fragment of Mars I have a smaller sample
of the Moon and these were all not
captured by me as an astronaut going
obviously because we haven't been to
Mars but it was brought by gravity and
the U.S Postal Service uh to my to my uh
to my lab and we examine them and you'll
get some data about these guys when you
join the mailing list but anyway the
point is we've been receiving material
from all these different planetary
bodies in our own backyard and that
implies if I'm not mistaken you'll
correct me but there's material from
earth that could have made it to other
regions of our own solar system
including these potentially fertile
places like Enceladus and you know maybe
Phobos I don't know you'll you'll you'll
correct all the errors that I'm probably
making but
what can we say about the
non-observation of life in our own solar
system as a laboratory just think in the
solar system as an extremophile
laboratory what can we say can we say
that you know there's less chance that
there's even slime mold or you know
those protozoa that were in uh your your
brilliant post-docs samples from Hudson
Bay what can we say about the
non-observation of of any form of life
in our own solar system where there's
there's definitely one source of life
it's here on Earth and it's been
exchanging material for at least a
billion years when since life has been
in existence can we say anything in a
Bayesian sense about the probability or
not of Life existing throughout the
cosmos so what's really interesting in
this and I love that you brought the
props
is that yes you can have microbial life
right but if even if you have the most
dirty microbial life if you throw it
into a completely different kind of
condition it doesn't need to strive
right if the conditions are similar it
can but if it's different it can't and
so there's this really interesting body
of research and there's no conclusion
yet how big such a meteorite would have
to be to bring enough material with it
to allow the biota to actually adapt to
the the the conditions outside right so
you'd have to survive for a while in the
condition that you brought and then you
could uh try to adapt to the conditions
outside and there is no consensus how
much material that would be but most of
the consensus is that these small pieces
are not enough
because they just don't give you enough
nutrition they don't give you enough
solvent whatever you're using but on the
flip side it was really funny and I love
that you brought you know that the Earth
of course shed those asteroids as well
right to all these other places that's
right but it was really interesting
because most of the time we come back to
saying oh so we're all martials right
because it's cooler to be a martian than
to be an Earthling I don't know why all
right the area it's kind of really
interesting because if you look at the
planets and moons in our solar system
and you mentioned Enceladus in your
Roper and typed in the three other
worlds in addition to Mars were we
trying to figure out if it could be life
then basically the Earth had the best
conditions for the longest because
liquid water on the surface we don't
know of any life that doesn't use liquid
water what's the longest around here on
the earth and so by taking that
we just really hope that any Martian
life we find is not a copy of Earth
because a it could have been like thrown
out and so then was it a second Genesis
and the second problem we have and we're
thinking about this very strongly
especially for Icy moons well we haven't
landed yet right so encelot is in Europa
in Titan we haven't actually landed on
yet is that on Mars we could have
brought hitchhikers yeah on early
emissions and then if those biota could
survive in Martian conditions right some
of them are extremely sturdy what about
if they survive and strive and if we
scoop our martial life it looks exactly
like home what does it mean does it mean
we're Martian doesn't mean they are
earthlings what does it mean life just
evolves similarly right and so that's
going to be a beautiful puzzle that we
hopefully don't have to solve because
what we're really hoping for in the
solar system is life that is kind of
different different amino acids or a
different kind of DNA structure or a
different kind of cell structure that's
what we're really hoping to find in our
search for life in the solar system yes
but but taking all the stuff we know we
know extrapolating out because the big
problem we have for planets that Circle
other stars is that we can't get there
we can drill through the ice and check
if there's actually life in the oceans
like for example an enceladist or on
Europa that also luckily have glaciers
so there's water spewing out so maybe we
don't have to land and have much an
easier way not to contaminate anything
by just flying through that spew of
whatever that comes at
but for other planets we'll have to use
our Earth the only place that we know
life is at to basically get as much
information as possible of what to look
for and thus Hudson Bay all these weird
kind of microbes that I usually don't
think about Yellowstone National Park
all this hot Lobby microns like you know
that I also usually don't think about
when I think about life and trying to
put a color catalog of life is what I
call it together so that we know what
our telescopes could pick up if life
that exists on Earth but in a niche
environment where the dominant life
somewhere else and just think about
algae blooms just think about a hugely
ocean cover with red algae or green
algae and this is when you can Envision
what I'm trying to talk about and what
kind of models I'm developing for us not
to miss Signs of Life just because we
might be a little bit too focused on
what we see outside when we look got it
okay I want to get to our nerding out
session you promised me the nerdiest
most fun uh set of lecture slides that
show me what I would have missed if I
could go back in time even though I'm
older than you a lot uh but I'd have you
as my professor anyway I don't care
we're not going to violate space-time
causality as Carl Sagan did as Ellie did
Airway in contact but anyway I want to
get to your nerding out because I love
that but first I want to ask you one
more emotional question this is
something I think about you don't have
to answer if you don't want to answer it
but if you could be guaranteed in your
career let's say the end of your career
which hopefully will be another 60 years
or more but let's say you get to the end
of the career and then you discover
slime mold on an exoplanet and you are
responsible for it you and your team and
you've discovered the first ever
evidence of life in the universe and it
comes with a little note and it says
we're the only form of life that ever
will be found in the entire galaxy let's
say okay or you could have one of your
great great great great grand PhD
students discover technological life a
thousand years from now
which do you take satisfaction in your
lifetime of discovering the only life
primitive slime mold that I have in my
refrigerator or would you let settle for
the knowledge that a thousand years from
now will make contact with a super
Advanced alien civilization step a
question I can't pick both no no no no
can the smile slime mode be like
technology advanced
bucket athletic green sponsor of the
podcast no I'm just kidding it's that
they're no longer
I do have to say is if we just find life
anywhere it doesn't have to be me can be
my grand grand phds whatever form of
life if we find it once we know it has
to be everywhere because we are so
crappy in finding it our Telescope yes
they are big they're beautiful they're
bringing a major amazing images down but
they are not a perfect tool or not even
a great tool yet to find these tiny tiny
signals for us to find life in the
universe and so if we find life just
once somewhere else that is not Earth's
life that we brought as a hitchhiker
then the universe must be teeming a life
and that is basically what I'm hoping
for and yeah well at the end of my life
can it be selfish at the end of my life
yes I think I actually think if we just
find slime mold that's going to be the
step that everybody's gonna jump on and
it's not going to take up a thousand
years to find the other slime molds and
the other technical civilizations if we
can find the first signs of life because
then it's going to be uh all out because
students are already so excited about
this research about that we could be the
generation where you find that if we're
alone in the universe that there are so
many brilliant lines that will have so
many better ideas than I could ever have
that will just take it and and move
forward wow and find stuff yeah we will
uh with with uh all the tools and
technology that your team uh is working
so diligently on so now we've come to
the nerding out session
um so I'd like to ask you to set up the
PowerPoint share the screen and just a
reminder you can win a meteorite
guaranteed win a meteorite uh if you
join my mailing list and use it.edu
email address and that's because I'm
trying to really be
um be forceful in my attempts to to
communicate with with students and my uh
my target audience my Target demographic
and some ways are students of all ages
but especially young people and and
helping them kind of navigate the what I
call the academic Hunger Games which
unfortunately is too common these days
and it starts with The Hunger Games of
getting rejected by Cornell I'm not
going to mention that uh So Lisa you've
got your screen I have never I've never
heard that and you know what if you want
to do a PhD with me just let me know
actually yeah that would be pretty dumb
thing yeah I'd have to leave you know La
Jolla which is which is quite a quite an
attractive place we have some life forms
here too which is I was about to say
you'd get to do snowman right now
instead of being in the warmth where you
just don't know what kind of seas
that drove my mother crazy and forced
her to move to the far south regions of
New York State on Long Island
um So Lisa we see your screen it's
showing me the presenter view uh instead
of the there we go perfect awesome okay
the screen is yours let the nerding
begin this is a treat everybody out
there leave a thumbs up if you love what
you're learning about and Lisa's uh
unique brand of Brilliance combined with
uh just irrepressible uh enthusiasm So
Lisa take it away thanks a lot so well I
wanted to just bring home just a couple
of points in our search for other births
and yes we found lots of different
planets but what I'm most interested in
is the one that could potentially be
like ours and that's of course ours that
you see on the slide but if you keep
going right so hours or a habitable plan
doesn't have to at all look at hours
right it hasn't have to be carbon copy
and so let's see what we found the first
thing that I did want to point out if
you want any more information the call
Sagan Institute at Cornell has about
third 40 faculty from about 15
departments and it's interdisciplinary
so we have biologists we have chemists
we have Engineers we have science
communicators we have arts and science
uh art it's in science so arts and
science engineering and we bio and we
have like Performing Arts everything
also how to communicate this amazing
excitement because there's so many
people who want to be part of this
search and this finding life and for
sharing it as Brian was saying before
you know this is only possible because
everyone
helps is interested in even if you don't
work on this right if you are interested
in our space in the universe this gets
us going with your enthusiasm with your
question on the street and you know with
the text knowledge that we spend on
telescopes like the huge James Webb
Space Telescope that we just launched
and so if you want to Deep dive I'll
give you a little deep dive but if you
want a real deep dive it's like there's
an animal reviewer wrote about this
topic how to characterize habitable
worlds and signs of life and so yes
annual reviews are pretty amazing
because they have scientists who spend
like about half a year I spent half a
year and hundreds of peppers uh
summarize the topic for you and I
strongly believe in that the best way to
teach or to think about something is to
try to show you the way I see things
because hundreds and thousands of papers
have gotten me to the point where I am
and the fastest way for me to learn from
somebody else is if they do the same it
does show me the way they see the way
they see the field the way that they
think about it and so I tried to do this
in the review so you know great just for
young people that might not be familiar
this is the most prestigious one of the
most prestigious uh outlets for for
astronomers to communicate not
necessarily as Lisa's saying original
research although she has some of her
own research in this article but it's
the the compendium of the Brilliance of
the field the hive mind of the field and
this uh journal and this uh in this
particular Journal is is the highest of
possible impacts on the field so thank
you for this I'll put a link to it in
the show notes below thank you but so if
you want to dive in that's a good place
to get started and there's lots of links
to where you can go from there but
where are we
we have more than 5 000 worlds that
Circle other stars right
so from 1995 when they found the first
one around a sunlight star and that's
the Nobel Prize of course for Michelle
mayor and Didier chaos who did that what
was amazing and super hard to do
we have more than five thousand known
world around other stars and that's
incredible because what that does it
gets you from looking at one object and
thinking about it to
an awesome and in an ensemble you can
see patterns and those patterns tell you
something about where these planets come
from how they are made what the
evolution of a planet is this is how we
figured out how the Stars work and live
like how our sun actually was born and
is going to die and now we wouldn't do
this for planets as well trying to get a
glimpse of the diversity and I promised
Brian to nerd out a little bit so
basically what you see here and don't
worry if you don't get the whole scoop
I'm just going to point out the most
interesting things here so what you see
on this axis is the radius of the
planets okay that's the y-axis goes up
and then on the right on the bottom the
x-axis this thing that goes to the right
is the periods in days
and then I've marked the size of mars or
Neptune and Jupiter here well what do
you see
we see two blobs right that's really the
most important thing here and one blob
is up at Jupiter or even higher and a
very short periods what that means is
the period I've shown you here is the
year on that planet we have 365 days so
a year on Earth is 365 days right so if
you go to the period of one day what
that means it's extremely hot because
you're so close to the star
so you see this blob so they seem to be
like huge fluffy Jupiters that's the
first ones we actually found very close
to their star and there's a second blob
when you see that most of the planets we
found are actually in size between Earth
and Neptune
so that's weird because Earth is the
biggest rocky planet we have and Neptune
is the smallest gaseous one
but it seems to be that most of the
planets there are are actually bigger
than ours smaller than Neptunes and now
the guessing game is on are they rocks
like yours called the worst or are there
mini Neptunes and the color coding is
just how hot their star is because it's
just easier to find planets around small
stars because the same size planet
around a smaller star makes the biggest
signal that's as easy as it is and if it
is vast in going around the start makes
a bigger signal then if it takes
hundreds of days this is why this whole
pattern is kind of a bit constrained by
observations too so that we haven't
found an earth analog and that we have
less and less planets when you go down
and to the right here so it's between
Earth and Mars and for higher periods is
just observational it's not that they
don't exist but the two blobs that you
see are actually especially if you cut
up the period around 100 or 30 days
these are real they're really in the
data and so apparently the most common
planet in the universe is one we don't
have in our system you know who knew who
could have even guessed
and so if I throw this around and I give
you
the radius and the mass
you know if you have a radius and if you
have mass you can get to the mean
density of an object so what do I mean
by that what I mean by that is if you
have the Earth and you
throw it in water it will sink if you
have Saturn the one with the Rings and
you throw it in water it would actually
swim because the mean density of Saturn
is lighter than water
SO gas planets are really completely
different than rocky planets and what we
find again here what you see is that we
have blobs so big blobs big Mass big
radius and then we have a small plop
here and this small blob is actually
where the rocky planets come in that
I'll show you in a minute
now this one is one of the tricky slides
that you'll see so bear with me for a
minute and if not just forget about this
one
I told you about the mean density if I
have radius and mass I can tell you if
something is a rock blue right like the
Earth that will sink in the water or a
gas planet like a Saturn because some
intensity is different another way to
think about it is I can tell you if this
thing is made out of rock or
marshmallows that usually gets the
attention of my students because they
were like what planets are made out of
marshmallows I was like no but I was
just checking if you're awake right they
have made up the gases were made out of
hydrogen and helium so completely
different than the Rocks but you have to
be a little bit careful because the mean
density of marshmallows is pretty close
to that and I learned that by looking it
up and so think about this hot
exoplanets as s'mores but because
they're hot they're close to the star
but s'mores made out of hydrogen helium
way less tasty to it
that's all I'm going to say about these
hot big planets because I'm really
interesting in this moment and so I'm
getting hungry too what do you see here
is lines
the dots you see here all the planets we
found the purple ones are the one in our
solar system so forget about the purple
ones V and E
is Venus and Earth here on the left side
and if you want more information in the
review that's all spelled out but
basically you can say if this planet is
made out of just iron that's the Fe on
the bottom 100 this is what it should be
and then you can say if the planet were
Earth-like that's the Green Line This Is
Where It should lie this is where we
should find it in terms of mass and
radians and what I find fascinating is
that we actually found already
a lot of planets that are from all we
know stimulator Earth composition
of course not for all of those we can
actually get mass and radius because
radius is when the planet goes between
us and the star so the light from the
Star dims a little bit and we can figure
out how
big the planet must be and then the mass
we get if actually the star wobbles
because the planet tucks on it but
that's a really hard measurement and we
use big telescopes from the ground to do
it so first order if something is
smaller than two Earth's radii roughly
it's a rock so when you hear something
in the news about a cool new planet in
the Amazon first check is it above or
below to Earth radii if it's more than
double the size of our own Planet it's
most likely a gas block still
interesting but not as interesting as if
it were a rock at least to me because
these gas flops I'm sorry to
interrupting but
um just to go back to the iron part uh
so when you receive these meteorites if
you're so lucky to win one if you don't
have an edu email list or if you have
one you'll win one
um they're mostly iron and you'll get
the Spectrum and I've done x-ray
fluorescence spectroscopy on them and
you know 90 87 iron and then the rest
are pretty heavy minerals as well Metals
as well that are that are magnetic and
so one of the tests I asked the students
to do or receive them is to play around
with these and magnets because you'll be
doing basically the experiment that
shows that they can't be pure that these
plants can't be pure iron but they have
to have some amount of iron and iron is
one of the most abundant elements of
course in the in the Galaxy so just
wanted to point that out that you'll
actually receive from from Lisa's
theoretical uh background you'll
actually receive some experimental
Hardware to play around with but yeah
and the best thing is to have
experimental Hardware like something in
your hand we're like oh my God that
could make out planets because because
all these tiny pieces that Brian is
talking about actually in the beginning
of the solar system smashed into each
other and made bigger and bigger and
bigger pieces until they formed the
earth and the other planets right
depending on how far away from the Star
they were they they grabbed more gas
than ice
and if they were close to the star where
it's really hot they were mostly Rocky
and so here you see how that turns out
the pictures you see the big one is
Jupiter and you see an incredible amount
of weather patterns on it the small one
of course is our own Earth but so just
to get a feeling how different these
planets are and so where should we look
right I thought I showed you all these
dots actually all these points I said we
have 5 000 planets well if you want to
find like where do you like and so I was
thinking about making this an
interactive thing with Brian but I don't
think I'm gonna put him on the spot too
much but think about it you close to the
star it's hot you further away from the
Star it's cooler right so orbital
distance you have a super hot planet a
lava world where everything melts then
you have a planet like Venus that lost
all its water and then you get to the
Earth habitat and so we've defined
something that's called a habitable
sound that's where surface water or
water could be liquid on a surface on a
rocky planet like the Earth it's a
handful but basically for us to find
life somewhere else it shouldn't be
under a huge layer of ice because that
makes the big problems in our solar
system right so for these icy moons with
the big ice
layer and celadus and a Euro bar we have
to go there and either drill through the
ice or fly through the Geisha the things
that they spew out to figure out what's
going on in the ocean beneath and if you
have a star very very far away that's
not going to work because we can't get
there so the only thing we have is light
but light and matter interact so when
light hits a molecule or an atom one
light hits a molecule in the atmospheric
Planet it starts to swing and rotate and
that leaves a Telltale sign in the light
that I received my telescope there's
something missing and that missing tells
me what the atmosphere of the planet is
made out of that's really what
astronomers do most of the time we look
for misting stuff to figure out what
chemicals the whole universe is made out
of
and so we know how bright the star is
and then we know at what distance it's
nice and warm at what distance it's way
too hot so you would actually melt the
rock on the surface yes there are
planets out there that would have love
or covered oceans not the ones we want
to go visit but there are out there from
what we find
and then if you're too far away from
your store you start to get frozen over
and then so far away like us to the next
star over so our star of course the sun
is eight light minutes away but the next
star over after that is about four light
years away so we can't get there so
Ithaca on the right is that Ithaca
that's what I'm about to say but no not
all of it is frozen over even so we are
still a little bit in the habitable
what's that but basically if you want to
think about it plus minus 70 of the
energy we get here in the earth is what
you're looking for two just hopefully
have oceans and rivers glistering so I
have a lot of more in-depth thing do you
really want to go and actually nerd out
or do you want to come back and just
talk about what we'll be looking for
piece by piece well I definitely want to
get to the questions of the audience so
um maybe with that we'll we'll uh we'll
we'll take we'll we'll postpone some of
the nursing for their questions at the
end that sounds perfect because I think
if you allow me what I will do I will
just go to the fun part so Earth of
course might give me five more minutes
so first of course has changed right
and I told you about all these different
things and you know the habitable sound
all of that depends what kind of gases
and volcanoes you have and you know what
can give you all links to that but if
you go just a little further think about
that Earth
would actually not be recognizable if
your time travel like I would love to go
with Doctor Who you gave me like finding
slime mold I really want to be on Doctor
Who study guide Tardis and just go and
actually explore the universe like they
do and they never have to worry about
breathing because of course the Earth
not just the at that the surface you
know all the continents moving and so on
but also the air changed but we can use
that so we know that the Earth's changed
we know the surface changed we know what
was on the surface changed and about 750
million years ago there was no green
land plants it started to be barren so
it becomes really really interesting to
think about if you were a time traveler
you wouldn't recognize a planet
there will be no more Himalayas Alps
anything because the continents have
shifted there's no more green the only
thing that could save you maybe is if
you know because
if you know the stars and you're like I
don't know what planet this is but at
least the sky looks familiar and so
what we did here and I thought that
might be a fun thing to talk about is
when I was we were talking about Hudson
Bay we were talking about Yellowstone
National Park
all these beautiful colors is different
kinds of life that are just non-dominant
here but we basically begged bored and
steeled is what I call it so we ask
everybody if they had some kind of biota
that they wanted to send us and we could
just basically uh measure what the what
they looked like what it would look like
to our telescope because that's
something biologists don't do because
they don't need that and then
astronomers don't have any biota because
we don't do that and so we have this
really interesting mix in my research
team and also the Carl Sagan Institute
we actually have a lab where we grow
stuff you know we is the Royal way
because I kill most stuff I grow so I
have an amazing team that grow stuff for
me and also the astronomy Department was
informing me that because apparently
Carl Sagan sent the Billy on fire at one
point we're not doing these experiments
in our astronomy Department anymore I'd
rather find somebody who has a bio lab
you know with all the equipment and so
we're doing that but it's just it's
different vibrant colors right I don't
know what kind of life could come out of
it if you and me would have like red
skin or green skin or you know if
dinosaurs would
be walking around with all different
kinds of colors or it's something
completely different but we know that if
part of the planet were covered with
this different kind of life we can spot
it in our telescopes
and this is one of the fun ones that we
had for the astrobiology it's a magazine
that we use and we got the cover for
this work of one of my students Lydia
Correo and so basically how would you
use that think about a frozen World
we're going back to when you were saying
you were actually seeing only Penguins
right a lot of Life can actually thrive
in ice and it can color that ice it's
one of the biggest problems we actually
or one of the problems we actually have
with climate change because if the ice
gets colored by biota that can all of a
sudden strive because it's warm the
reflectivity of the ice will go down and
it will warm faster and so in a way it's
pretty funny how again these different
researchers come together because I want
to know about this so to find it on
another planet somewhere else in my
telescope
and people on the Earth want to know
about this to figure out how to help or
mitigate climate change and so
one last thing that Brian was allowing
me to do is to do another fun aspect so
we have where are we looking we found 5
000 planets where are we looking what's
this habitable sound right well
determined by we cannot look through ice
or something that's so far away that we
can get there
but
once you think about the other signal
which is a life that you can look in
your telescope one thing that's that
jumped out at me was the question is
like so who could see us
if they were life and you know we have
talked about this there might be zero or
there might be billions right
if they were life and they had just our
level of technology so we find most of
the planets because the star dims a
little bit when the planet goes between
us and the hot Stellar surface of the
star The star looks as if it was less
bright still the same brightness we just
don't see all of
the surface and so then we said well how
many stars could see us that way and it
turns out this was with a friend with a
colleague of mine Jamie fajardia the
American Museum of Natural History turns
out you have about 2 000 stars that
right now within 300 light years that's
not much could see us and the fun part
about it is where are we the aliens
that's right they are actually 75 of
those where also the radio waves would
have already passed by them so they
couldn't just see that they're dimming
up our star they could also listen to
really bad music and television from a
while ago you know it's getting better
with time but you know I'm a bit biased
some of those already are known to host
planets within this habitable zone I was
talking about
and we are observing more and more of
this and one thing that I really liked
about this is there were headlines about
this paper they were so funny it was
like two thousand ways Earth has blown
its cover and then there was somebody
was saying ooh are you feeling watched
so with that and I can actually give you
some relaxation what maybe in terms of
gases in the atmosphere but I do not
think that anybody can like zoom in all
these worlds hundreds of light years
away it is kind of interesting to just
think about
if we could have been discovered and
that gets back to your question Brian
right so why is nobody here
use acid for the solar system but you
can also ask it for wider field right if
the universe is teeming with life
um why do we not find anything and no
UFO sightings can actually stand up
unfortunately because I'd love
to have there to be signs of life that
comes and visits us it would shortcast
my research and I wouldn't have to wait
until the end of my career for slime
mold or a thousand years for technical
Advanced if somebody were landing and
saying hey we're aliens that would help
me so much much more than the hard way
of trying to find uh life on other
planets but what's really really
interesting in this is when I ask my
students
I say okay let's say it's hard to travel
or it's actually hard to communicate or
you know it just costs a lot to
communicate and I have two planets
two plans with Signs of Life One is five
thousand years younger than us
and one is five thousand years older
than us I can only do one in terms of
communication or getting to which one
should I pick
yeah which one do you pick Brian I
picked the more advanced one but uh I
picked the more advanced one too yes
ninety percent of the people I ask and
so if you turn that around
you know I love our planet Earth is my
favorite planet I I Adore it but
if their universe is teeming with
civilizations
are we really the people you want to
come and visit because you know face it
we had boots on the moon but we haven't
even gotten humans to other planets yet
so in terms of Interest we might not be
the most interesting people out there if
there's life out there
and so that was just kind of the thing
where I wanted to bring it around to
what he asked and then we're going to
get the questions yeah in case somebody
wants some more information I thought
the review this is basically some
thoughts I had and then you know feel
free to email me or ask me on Twitter or
any questions that you have but
hopefully we'll have some now right yeah
we have a whole bunch now but I'm gonna
take the host host prerogative and ask
uh the first one if uh Alien uh
exoplanatiers exoplanetary biologists at
their own you know Sagan Center
somewhere distant distant Lisa if they
haven't jwst how far out could they spot
Tokyo uh you know how you know could uh
Trappist one which you've had some great
involvement with could they you know are
they close enough far they're too far
away to actually use a technology like a
six meter infrared telescope to spot a
mega city on earth
so mega cities you actually can do
there's a paper on this and it actually
says that you have to be pretty much in
our solar system before you can see mega
cities but gases that we breathe in and
out oxygen with reducing gas like
methane that basically we cannot explain
with anything else about life that you
can see from far far away and we showed
in our research that you can see that
for about two billion years in Earth's
history because of course before there
was not much oxygen so you couldn't do
that and if life makes just CO2 and
methane then you have the problem that
you can get that from volcanoes too so
you need unique signatures extraordinary
evidence for Extraordinary discoveries
is called faganzan and so you can go
pretty far out but the question is
always as you know in science and your
viewers might not know this but it
always is the question how much time do
we get because the James Webb is an
amazing instrument
and it has completely changed how we can
see the universe the problem is it
hasn't just changed it for exoplanets
because there are these pesky people who
want to know something about the early
universe or black holes or Galaxy
Evolution who do not understand that we
just want to use all the time on x sub 1
x that was of course a joke I think
for me because I love exoplanets this is
the most important thing because so many
other interesting things that other
scientists want to do and they are
amazing so we don't get too common to
hear the James Webb Space Telescope just
to find life on other planets
unfortunately so if an alien
civilization could they could be pretty
far out actually and still find life on
our planet very good okay first question
that we have here comes from long time
friend of the channel Jimmy Jazzy uh he
wants to know your views on the origin
of life
um and he has a further sub comment
about Darwin and uh you can we don't
have to get into that uh Jimmy but uh
what do you think about the origin of
life as you said you know if we find
martians and they're really earthlings
or maybe we're earthlings in their
marshes that just you know defers the
question maybe of how life originated it
doesn't solve the question of how life
originated what are your thoughts uh I
know it's not exactly your field of
research but you are you know this pan
dynamic
um uh Institute director so what are
what are the current leading thoughts on
origin of life from your perspective as
an astrophysicist so what's really
interesting and I'm with you there you
know it's like how do we now know how
life started on the earth how is that
even possible right when I started to do
the evolution of Earth on uh you know my
models on the evolution of Earth I just
thought we knew so much more than we do
and it's fair right it's hard to know
because the further you go back the less
records you have the less fossils you
have and then life actually starts to
have nothing to uh to actually contain
in those fossil records because there
were no more bones no more feathers you
know it becomes squishy and so it's hard
to actually find it but so the major
theories right now is that you could
have kind of three regions where life
should have evolved it could have
evolved one is on the bottom of the
ocean where we have something that's
called black and white smokers where
it's super super cold but there are
regions where like super hot water with
a lot of sulfur gets spun out from the
ocean flooring and that temperature
gradient actually allows for a chemical
gradient and the chemical gradient is
key to try to get some kind of chemicals
together to make a cell-like structure
to make dna-like structure we think it's
RNA and then DNA the second one that's
kind of the running winner for now but
you know not winner it's just like a lot
of people believe that that would be the
easiest way to do it is a shallow water
hypothesis that just means you have a
shallow pond there's chemistry in the
water right it gets hot you evaporate
some of the water it gets more it gets
more concentrated and then on the bottom
of that pond if it's like clay or
something there are some things that
just cling together and form the first
kind of structures cells RNA this is how
you start to go and then the third one
that's a little bit less favored is that
you could do it in ice because when you
freeze something you also concentrate
the chemistry in the resulting water if
there's just a little bit of water left
most of it is actually highly
concentrated chemistry and then you
could melt it a bit more and again make
it more
um
versatile but the problem is that if you
have the huge ocean
you don't concentrate the chemistry
enough to get life started so you either
have to have shallow Waters bottom off
the ocean with a temperature gradient
and chemistry gradient coming out or
maybe an ice where you actually freeze
and de-freeze the water
very good very good so um there's
another question coming in from longtime
friend of the channel uh Andy Oates and
he's asking uh about how does the
equation change with the discovery of
exomoons and and even of asteroids with
oh with Moon moons but I want to um well
first get your take on that and then I
want to ask you about a Cornell alumnus
uh passed away sadly last year Frank
Drake and his eponymous equation but
first does the discovery that there are
in fact EXO moons does that raise or
lower the probability of finding life
given that the moon on Earth's moon is
responsible for our tidal phenomena and
the black smokers and stuff or related
tectonic activity tidal activity also
seems to play a role in these
stromatolites that extremophiles have
been found in anyway Lisa what is the
discovery of uh of exomoons do for the
chances of Life of any kind and maybe
even of technological life's probability
as a theorist
so
one we haven't found an x amount yet but
we're desperately looking there are some
indications that there could be some but
there's no definitive accident yet but I
said billions of billions a little cheek
easily because of course Carl seconds
book billions and billions but we are
very conservative you know one out of
five stars had a planet at the right
distance small enough to be a rock
within this habitable zone but then
there could be billions more of moons
out there that could provide around gas
giants places for life like you know
Enceladus and Europa doing and Titan
hopefully do an hour so let's
so there are so many other options that
we haven't even explored yet that could
also give us environmental life could
strive and so I kind of really like our
chances and so when we go back to the
second point on this is do you need a
moon to be habitable there we come into
something that I find fascinating and
that I had to grow out of because it is
so easy to just look around it's like oh
yellow sun so life needs a yellow sun
ooh Moon so life needs a moon right and
yes the moon stabilizes our season and
there's lots of other things going on
that the moon does for us and for life
on the Earth but it is because life on
the earth developed because with the
moon right it didn't develop because the
Moon from everything we know but it it
of course used everything in its
environment to strive and so if you take
the Moon away in a planetary scenario we
probably the planet doesn't have a
problem that life on it probably doesn't
have a problem because it basically
evolves without a planet having without
a moon being there and when you look at
our solar system it's so interesting why
we have a moon in the first place right
well Venus doesn't have one Mars has two
tiny caught things and Mercury doesn't
have one right and a big question that
people are trying to figure out is that
maybe because of the huge impact we
think there was a mars-sized object that
hit the earth and then threw part of it
out to make a moon first a ring and that
formed a moon
maybe that got tectonic kickstarted
and maybe that helped but on the other
hand Mars should have had tectonic
initially too and it never went through
this Collision so it's going to be super
important to find other planets and get
our info from there from the patterns
and when you were talking about life
before it's like how can we figure out
where life started on the earth well
think about it this way if you find lots
of earths that are frozen and have
always been frozen and they show sign of
life then a cold start is likely if you
find lots of Earth that are hot and only
they show kind of light then a hot start
is likely and so we basically piece
together what happened in our own planet
and how life started from the other
places where we get information from as
scientists always do
very good uh so long-term uh friend of
mine uh has at least half his name
shared with the namesake of the Carl
Sagan Center and that's Fred Carl asking
do we have a carbon life form bias in
other words do we sort of have this
predisposition that life must have
evolved elsewhere in the universe as it
did on Earth in terms of uh primarily
based on or entirely based on carbon and
so-called organic chemistry is that is
that a fair bias that we should continue
to hold on to or should we put it in the
dust bin Speck of of dust in in history
yes we do have a bias
however
it's quite interesting because if you
look at the Earth like for example
silica just thinks that people talk
about you know instead of carbon that
you could use we have that on the earth
there's actually more silicate on the
earth than there's carbon it's just
locked in rocks
and the problem is it doesn't make gases
very easily either you have to go
actually very high in temperature to
have a silicate
s-i-sio2 for example
and so the question really comes down to
under what condition is carbon and water
your best bet
and this habitable sound that we have
defined right is basically for that best
bet the solvent being water and then the
backbone probably being carbon but if
you just think about Titan for example
where we hope there could be life this
is why we're standing a super cool
quadcopter we're sending a quadcopter to
another moon in our solar system I just
think that's super cool yeah part of the
Carl Sagan Institute is working on that
and I just get updates and I'm like so
cool can I fly it they won't let me play
it but you know after what happened in
the lab with that uh explosion and yeah
that was Carl Sagan yeah
the point is boy Titan it's too far out
it's a moon of Saturn yes and so it's
too cold there's no liquid water on the
surface but there are lakes of Ethan and
methane so different solvent
could absolutely be biased base for life
and so people are looking into how you
could get similar kind of life started
how could you make a cell structure with
a different kind of solvent how could
you make life backbone with something
that's not carbon but there's really a
lot of good reasons for carbon a it's
one of the most abundant things in the
in the universe carbon hydrogen and
oxygen
and also
life on the earth showed that it was
incredibly good at using whatever around
and it used carbon
so in other places where carbon is
incredibly abundant it's kind of hard to
imagine why it would just say oh not
using that one use something else except
if you bring in temperature if you bring
in temperature then the solvents need to
change because other than that ice is
just going to be block of ice right so
what is going to be a block of ice and
so there's lots of fascinating things
and so
um yeah absolutely we have a carbon bias
um because we can make life in the lab
yet if we could make life in the lab we
could just throw you know something else
in inside of carbon and try to figure it
out and a friend of mine at Harvard was
just so funny because I asked him so
what about life in the lab how hard is
it right and they were like well it's
the most terrible PhD project because
you need something to publish in three
years right it's just like it could be
tomorrow three years oh my God why would
you want the square root of the number
of years that I have my graduate student
just kidding I don't do that but the
interesting thing about this is just to
say that you don't know how long you
have like let's say this is the bath for
how life could get started right so when
do you change the parameters did life
need a thousand years did it need five
minutes to get the initial thing started
you know if you just change it a little
too fast you've missed it even if the
parameters were right or if you change
it too slow it's going to take you
thousands of years to figure it out so
trying to make life in the lab is
fascinating and incredibly hard to do so
but if we could then we could actually
work on our carbon bias for now we can
only look for stuff that we know makes
life
Lisa do you have time for a few more
questions uh absolutely sorry and I'm
going to try to be shorter so no no no
it's it's so it's so fascinating but
there's just so many questions you can
leave your question in the live chat or
in the comment of the video afterwards
I'll I'll send the link to Lisa and
she'll maybe troll the comments section
and and say we have to get a better host
for the into the impossible podcast
um so I want to ask you a question that
is kind of aligned with my curmudgeonly
side and that comes from Sam Adams
founder of this country
um and he shares with you that I find
um somewhat persuasive uh here's what he
says he said he's not actually asking a
question but he's making a statement he
says only 10 of the stars in the galaxy
are like our sun Jupiter and Saturn's
orbits are kind of act like vacuum
cleaners uh they they scoop up dangerous
comets and asteroids luckily not the
green Comet which you can see tonight uh
we'll have some information about that
on our Twitter feeds uh but the uh they
kind of act as bodyguards for the Earth
protect in the Earth the Moon distance
to the to the Earth of our moon and only
a single moon is quite favorable most
stars are binary stars in the galaxy I
think that's correct
um anyway he's basically saying there is
no one else uh in the Galaxy let alone
uh you know Advance life form uh not
even slime mold there's too many terms
in the Drake equation so to speak that
are inhospitable to life and then he
adds on echoing some of my homogeneous
he says be glad there's no one else in
our galaxy because it would be a
disaster if we did meet them how do you
react to these uh these pessimists Lisa
you're such a cheerful person what do
you do on your down days do you ever
think oh my God this Sam Adams guys are
right uh you know there's just too many
variables in the Drake equation that
aren't really captured in the kind of
nuisance variables but those are the
most important things the plus or minus
I like to say the interesting thing of
the Drake equation is not the equation
solution it's the error bars that you
put on it because they can be anywhere
from zero to a hundred percent of the
value so anyway how to react to this um
this Rare Earth as Donald brownley and
others have called it that there's so
many things that are so improbable
there's really zero chance sorry to
break it to you at the Carl Sagan
Institute but maybe you'll become a
cosmologist and uh you'll get your
second PhD how do you react Lisa
I think it's great to bring this up
because you know when I talk about this
you could be like oh she's like
optimistic about all these things and so
on so let me just unpack a couple of
these things and this is where we're
saying that sometimes it's so hard for
us not to
just see or see the things that are
around us because of course that's where
we get the patterns from right so this
is why when I was talking about you know
we need to find different kinds of life
or look at least look for them but let
me unpack this just to a little so
Jupiter Saturn let's just talk about you
know what hits the Earth it's like it's
actually there's a really interesting
paper that I like and it's just like I I
remember the title because it was just
such a cool title Jupiter friendofo
because when you look into it Jupiter
actually does as much harm as it saves
us because yes it collects a lot of
these pieces that will be throwing onto
the Earth but it's also the reason
because of its huge gravity that those
pieces keep starting to flow in the
first place right so it's kind of if you
look at it in detail it's kind of a wash
and then the question is what would have
happened if there would have been more
impact right maybe in fact that's
actually very interesting in biology
maybe impacts are actually the thing
that get life to devolve further right
remember there were this extinctions
event in life history and after that
life actually started to Blossom you
know would it have ever developed from
slime mold if we never would have had
this pressure this environmental
pressure for it to evolve right so
that's that part and then the Moon part
I completely you know we we have this
Moon and it seems to be such a beautiful
special thing and I love our moon not
even a question they do but think about
it this way if you go back in Earth
history the moon initially was very
close to us we know that because the
Moon is still moving away from us so
what that means we can calculate that if
the Earth must have had a much faster
rotation when it was young so about
eight hours is what we expect it to be
half been early so what that now tells
you is the rotation rate of the planet
cannot make much of a difference because
other than that life wouldn't have
started here right so the 24 hours is
actually quite late in terms of rotation
rate and by the way you gaining like
nanoseconds per year so the the day is
getting tomorrow is just a tiny bit
longer than today if you're looking for
the extra hour in your day kind of have
to look for a while but
um getting better and so
a lot of things that seem very special
to us
are actually just because we see the end
results of all of it
and just think about if you had an ocean
right even if you have lots of impacts
if you had weird season
life on the bottom of the ocean wouldn't
care right it wouldn't even care about
the composition of the air right because
you wouldn't need that composition of
the air yes maybe it would never get on
land if there were land
because there's some kind of radiation
on the surface of the planet and so on
and the second thing that I wanted to
mention what was really surprising in a
way we got super lucky
you go completely right there now many
uh yellow stars like the sun the
Yellowstone is a very standard star but
it's not the most abundant one the most
abundant one is tiny small not so
massive red Suns so when you look around
somehow we don't know why Mother Nature
if you want made much more rocky planets
around these small stars
there is a component of how this makes
sense because the disc that forms around
the star to make these planets about one
percent of the star's Mass doesn't have
so much stuff so you can make rocks
rocky planets the small ones but you
can't make big Jupiters because you
don't have enough stuff to do it and so
what we find is these small stars that
are most abundant in the universe
actually have most rocky planets within
this habitable zone and so we hadn't
even talked about Trappist one one of
the really interesting fascinating
planets Red Sun uh with seven erst size
planet and four of them within the
habitable zone boundaries so they could
be four Earth there there could have
just be no life whatsoever right but
this is of course one of the
high priority targets we have for James
Webb and we have some super interesting
information that I can tell you because
I'm not the first author but it would
come out
and so what I'm just saying is that I
love the question because it allows you
to unpack our biases and I have these
biases absolutely the same when I
started out and then I talk with
biologists and geologists more and then
you figure out what you think is
desperately needed for life is not what
life needs to get started or even evolve
so this Rare Earth
is maybe also born in little beds in the
hope that we might be unique but you
know if it turns out not to work out
Brian I'll take you up on your PhD
that's right the beauty is there's never
a shortage of things to learn about okay
we have a lot more questions than than
we have time for but let's keep going
with a couple more uh a question coming
from uh again from Andy Oates who really
should go and do a PhD with Lisa does
Lisa think a binary planetary system in
the habitable zone or green zone as he's
calling it has a better chance of
showing
um uh Advanced evolutionary processes in
other words does your location in the in
the habitable zone too close too far
you're still in the Goldilocks zone but
but nevertheless does that in a binary
with a multiple planetary system does
that increase chances for advanced life
forms or does that have no effect
thanks for the question because I was
curious about that a couple of years ago
and so I actually figured out where the
hydro zone is for binary star and of
course you know I'm also a Star Wars fan
in a certain point and so I wanted to
know if Tatooine could be real right
that's right we actually found planets
around four stars so Tatooine is kind of
not as Visionary as you might think so
science that's actually overtaken sci-fi
what is amazing I love it I love sci-fi
I love the connection so don't take this
with a grain of salt but what about the
evolution of life right so whether you
have one or two stars kind of doesn't
matter
because you will evolve for it right
even if you think about it if the if the
planet most likely or most of the
planets we found around binary systems
actually orbit both stars and so that is
a light light source instead of one on
the sky it's like Tatooine right you
have two stars that give you the light
but it doesn't matter because they go
around each other like that so you
always kind of see both of them so you
always get the same amount of light and
so there shouldn't be any difference
between the evolution if gonna if
everything else being the same on a
binary star planet than another one but
we do know that it's going to be harder
to make more planets around binaries
because the problem is you start to
truncate this disc with two stars
especially if the planet actually orbits
one of the two stars that happens too so
if the planet orbits one of the two
stars the other star also has a
gravitational pull on this disc from the
outside that again truncates it so you
only have so much stuff that can make
planets but fascinating and it's kind of
harder to find planets that want to
start because there are two stars that
you have to get rid of instead of one in
terms of signal so this is why we're not
as why we haven't found as many planets
around binary stars as we have around
single stars but most of the stars are
in binaries so 50 so yes we luckily
found planets around those too all right
now let's go to like yes or no short
answer so we can answer everybody's
question
um Verdi
um again we have some famous famous
channel members here uh Verdi's asking
um you know about life not the music
that's right although you must be
partial to Mozart uh yeah but la
Traviata is still my favorite oh wow
this is incredible I love I love the
fact that Mozart and uh and Doppler grew
up in the same town and they're both
have relevance to most astrophysicists
but anyway he's asking about a magical
Shield but I'm going to convert that to
a magnetic field
um our magnetic fields we'll just do
short answer magnetic fields are they
critical for evolution of any form of
life on a on a planet a rocky planet
life on the surface very likely life in
the ocean on the bottom probably not as
long as you have enough air left that
liquid can be liquid like water can be
liquid got it uh Tony Nagy who asks a
lot of Naji asks a lot of questions he's
good uh good supporter of the channel uh
does the Oort cloud Shield Us in some
way from maybe Avi loeb's uh
Interstellar uh assaults uh does the
Oort cloud play a role in evolution of
habitable planets
so
um we don't think so the really
interesting thing is about even the
belts in our own solicits and the
asteroid and the Kuiper belt right why
is there no planet we don't really know
why it didn't form a planet but the ort
Cloud out is again A plus minus because
it can bring material in to bring for
example things like water but it can
also lead to huge impacts that could
maybe actually deter light for make
extinct life so again it seems to be
like a wash but because it's so far out
and so far away
we don't know if you just took it away
completely what would happen yes So
speaking of the art cloud you may see
one of its former citizens uh the green
Comet uh Comet uh discovered and at
least in the last 50 000 years ago since
the last 50 000 years discovered by the
zwiki transient facility at Mount
Palomar in San Diego County uh not too
far from where I am on campus and that
uh so-called green comment visible
tonight with binoculars uh as it makes
its closest approach to the Earth
225 million miles away from the earth so
look for that Elisa maybe you'll get a
spot at that that beautiful Observatory
that you guys have on campus um so we
have a clear night it is called and
you're away from most of the city lights
although Ithaca is quite quite developed
I don't know if you could spot it with
uh from another from Trappist you know
7B
um how many of those planets uh Verdi's
asking again are totally locked orbiting
um he's asking about red dwarfs I think
he might be thinking of Jill tarters
coined cornelian term brown dwarfs but
but anyway how many title locked planets
might be orbiting around either dim
stars or failed Stars Brown dwarfs is
that do we know about that
so basically for the red stars the
smallest cells that I was talking about
absolutely if you in the habitable zone
if you're so close that you get similar
energy because the star is smaller right
so it is not as luminous to get similar
energy that the Earth does you start to
get tightly locked what means is
synchronously locked one face always
facing the star one face uh never facing
the star like the moon does to the Earth
like the moon does to the Earth but the
interesting thing is life doesn't need
light
three quarters of the life on the earth
actually doesn't do photosynthesis it
doesn't need it it gets energy from
chemistry or some other ways and so
basically this is again the bias that we
have because the life that's on the
surface right that's nice and green and
that's photosynthesis is what we see
every day so it's easy to think that
that's the life that's out there and so
I Envision such a world pretty amazingly
you can calculate when they start to get
tightly locked and it's a couple most of
them in the hobblestone should be
totally locked because the age of the
Stars a couple of billion years long
story short but think about it you
basically have Sun forever and then when
you want to get tired you just walk it
to dust and Dawn and then you keep
walking and maybe you have like a
biofluorescent life world kind of biota
on the other side I just can imagine an
amazing sci-fi uh movie coming out of
this so you know Brian just keep an eye
open on somebody picking this up that's
right and you do have a movie that's
available on Apple uh iTunes and so
forth what's the name of that movie that
you appeared in documentary that's
actually a documentary about the search
for life and space and it's amazing
visuals of space and it came in 3D in
the imix and so I was like can I touch
it it's probably as close as I ever
gonna be to touching the other planets
in our solar system because I don't have
any plans to become an astronaut but
yeah I think it's amazing what we know
about the planets and moon in our solar
system and now we start to learn about
planets circling out the Stars oh wow
okay so the next is about uh from
Channel War Horse uh name I almost chose
from one of my children
um he's asking about AI life um but um
uh I wonder he's asking if the does the
existence of advanced AI does it tell
what does it tell us about about humans
and and maybe perhaps to infer a little
bit more than he's asking uh you know
are we more likely to see an AI
astronaut you know as evidence of
extraterrestrial intelligence than a
physical UFO hovering over you know
downtown Ithaca
I think we need a couple more podcasts
to unpack that question okay fine
because you agree it will come back I
would just say it links to what's our
future going to be because like right
now we haven't decided yet right if all
civilizations go the road of AI right
you don't need any food anymore you
don't need anything we basically up all
upload ourselves in the clouds but on
the other hand is this really what we're
going to do are we going to just use it
to our Mentor ourselves like to help us
remember and so on we haven't made that
choice yet and so it's very hard to
guess what a completely different aliens
like Civilization would make in that
kind of choice and what their life spans
would be compared to ours if it's a
fraction of a second they probably don't
travel the Stars if it's millions of
years then traveling the stars is not
such a big deal
um yeah that's right although what
someone is asking why would they even
get off their couches when they can just
put on a AR headset and just be in the
metaverse all day long
um okay so that'd be scientists like us
and we could also just sit and binge
watch something but we want to figure
new things out it's just kind of a
feeling inside and I'm sure everybody
has the Curiosity about something
scientists are just incredibly tenacious
to figure things out right
um the last question that we'll take
before I wrap up with a couple of my own
uh comes from dadson worldwide who asks
an interesting question can can the
existence of exoplanets or specific
exoplanets tell us anything about the
Galaxy in which it inhabits uh is there
any way to determine say from the
spectroscopy and the predictions that
you make from a theoretical perspective
could we sort of invert that and learn
about you know for one thing you learn
if there's iron pure iron planet that
that star forming uh raid in that Galaxy
must have been quite high in the
Superman of our rate must have been
quite high can you learn about the
Galaxy Lisa from any of the observations
of exoplanets that are cosmological or
Galactic physics from exoplanet physics
so that would make my job recruiting
much much easier here I think it
definitely can because a lot of times
what's very interesting is when you see
a completely other distribution of the
exoplans you found in another galaxy
let's assume that's what you see right
then you'll have to figure out why and
that will have to link with what kind of
stars have been made what the stars are
made out of and that will link back to
what happened in that Galaxy we can only
do this for close by one trade because
you need light why is that Galaxy so
different from ours and gives you a
different angle of course you can
observe all the other things like which
stars does it have what's the center of
the Galaxy and so on was the movement
but it gives you a different angle to
ask the same question and the more
angles you have to figure out a result I
think the more you can learn yeah okay
Lisa you've been such a phenomenal guest
there's people demanding that you come
back for a part part two I know you have
a busy and demanding schedule research
and teaching and everything that you do
for the cosmos but I can't help but but
Echo back to uh to the namesake of the
Sagan Institute uh and that is Carl
Sagan it looks kind of angry here I want
to get a dollar view uh Elisa I want to
distribute these dolls of you but but
Carl Sagan said uh um famously a book is
proof that humans can work magic because
you have this this article this this
piece of of incredible you know
intelligence maybe or maybe not if it's
uh if it's this book here my my first
book uh but but at any rate you have
this this kind of archive of a human's
experience and distilled and I want to
ask you kind of in keeping with that
quote that a book is proof that humans
can Can Do Magic I want to ask you the
kind of update to that I say a podcast
is proof that humans can do magic
because now we can save the voice of the
actual author the The Thinker the
scientist in your case and we can
preserve that forever
and as Arthur C Clarke said once he said
that any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
Magic I want to ask you looking into
your crystal ball what kind of
um what kind of technology or almost uh
incomprehensible technology do we have
now that in the future people will look
back on and say that was really magical
it could be a discovery it could be
something that you particularly have
discovered what fact or what aspect of
the universe that you've encountered
maybe even you've discovered do you find
most magical
I think in our lifetime
we found the first planet around another
star and this is a royal way but it took
all of us to get there
and that planet for me
changed our trajectory as humans right
and if you think about it in the longer
time scale think about a history book
and maybe there's going to be two eight
bucks the time before humankind knew
that they weren't alone hopefully the
time after and I really hope we are just
at that break because I want to go out
at night look up see the green comment
absolutely but I want to look up and say
like around that star
there's a planet that could be like ours
and maybe someone
is looking up right now wondering about
us too
uh Lisa I think you've uh done more than
almost anybody I know to inspire young
people and old people like me uh to just
be fascinated by the the actual
contributions that that a human being
small compared to the size of the cosmos
as Sagan once said uh and yet has
infinite worth and infinite capability I
want to thank you so much for coming on
the into the impossible podcast I hope
uh the questions didn't get too much and
I hope people connect you on Twitter we
have links to your Twitter Twitter bio
uh down below uh the Carl Sagan
Institute and and follow Lisa as I do
for more information as I said uh please
do subscribe to my mailing list if you
have a edu email address you'll
guarantee to win a meteorite because I
want to really promote you know stem
education to all my students locally and
virtually out there in the metaverse and
I want them to connect with great
thinkers and and I strive to do that on
this channel as you have witnessed today
with one of my favorite interviews of
all time bucket list interview made up
for me not getting into Cornell and
that's Lisa uh caught the dagger thank
you so much Lisa and I wish you a very
successful rest of your day enjoy the
winter there you know I'm just so
envious of you the cross-country skiing
you can do there is just it's just so
envious thank you so much Lisa thanks so
much for having me thanks for all the
great questions you guys have done and
you know think about it and get us help
to try to find life in the universe and
you know Brian my offer still stands if
you want another PhD I can kind of
guarantee that we'll accept you and
Connell this time okay well we'll see if
the the donation check clears this time
um Lisa thank you so much and I will be
seeing you hopefully this fall uh in
lovely Ithaca Fair Ithaca and we'll
we'll go Gorge diving together with uh
with my kids and you hopefully